this is atrocious I can't take the the
loss of Liberty every single day I am
Nicholas be with reason TV and we're at
the international students for liberty
conference in Washington DC and today
i'm talking with gigi bowman gigi is the
author of how to run for office on a
Liberty platform you are a candidate for
state Senate in new york in new york
state from Long Island and you are also
the head of Liberty candidates let's
talk about a couple of things first of
you know you're interested in helping
people who want to run on a Liberty base
or freedom based platform run for office
what is the biggest challenge in running
on a Liberty platform most of the people
who are running the biggest challenges
money and they can't seem to get the
donations that they really deserve these
are people who are running for office
who actually are awake and aware it
started out being for people who were
running and inspired by Ron Paul ok so
that's where we began and during that
whole time period we have had Ron Paul
running twice for president and
basically everybody was giving their
money to round Paul so now we're in a
time where Ron Paul's not running people
might be able to look around and
actually donate now to Liberty
candidates so I'm hoping that there's a
change and is the idea to run Liberty
candidates as a kind of protest vote or
for them to actually get into office and
change things I would love for them to
get into office um we do not ask what
party anybody's and so we have a variety
of people Democrats our Liberty
candidates conservative party
Republicans so what's the core of the
Liberty platform as as your group to
find him it's actually the same core of
campaign for liberties which started out
sound money free market individual
liberty constitutional government and
non-interventionist foreign policy that
was the big difference what is it you
know that now that Ron Paul has gone
into retirement from polina from
political life what was it about him
that just caught fire with so many
people in it you know in so many ways is
an unlikely you know Kai
a spark of freedom it turned on young
people he turned on old people he
brought people had never been interested
in the politics before what was it about
his message and the way of delivering it
that that lit so many fires actually i
think it was common sense whenever you
spoke it wasn't with air as it wasn't
something that people had to decipher
figure out he spoke in a way that was
easy to understand and really resonated
with everyone that was just it's like a
natural born thing to feel you want to
be free and he made sense and he always
made sense what's the one thing that
somebody who's thinking about running
for an office should make sure to avoid
I think they shouldn't step up and run
for a federal office right away you
should run locally run for assembly run
for something where you're going to have
a say in your community and go from
there but don't think you're going to
just step up and run for Congress and
when it's not going to happen you need
to you need to have people believe you
trust you and the best way to do that is
to do it in your own neighborhood where
you're going to run for state Senate in
New York from Long Island what are your
what are your key issues why you know
you're not somebody who has long been
interested in running for office why now
and what what's the most pressing issue
for you I didn't want to run for office
but I decided to do it after we had the
New York gun ban voted on and most of
the votes came from Republicans and that
was kind of shocking to a lot of the
people in my area because they worked so
hard to get Republicans in that they
wouldn't vote for things like this it
was it was a shock and it made me angry
because they pushed it through in the
mill the night they didn't have time to
read the bill it's just a matter of so
many different things how can we push
bills through in the middle of the night
and I mean the bill is is you've got to
take at least you know two days to read
it and you've got a matter of hours that
made me mad but my biggest my biggest
issue is Big Pharma that they're trying
to push through legislation to force our
children to have vaccines the gardasil
vaccine which is really it's got very
questionable side effects and they want
to do with our parents will consent
there's actually two bills working
together this is atrocious I can't take
the the loss of Liberty every single day
and my state seems to be number one on
the hit parade trying to just make a
slave so well where is the
best place for people to get more
information about your doe qu jie jie
bowman for spelt out fo our Senate calm
about the campaign if you want to run
for office go to liberty candidates calm
and fill out the application if you
believe that you are running on a
platform of Liberty and you want to be
endorsed by us it's a great place to be
because we have about 500 candidates
that are listed as Liberty candidates
that you know you can trust okay that's
great and then the book is how to run
for office on a Liberty platform and
that's available at amazon okay we've
been talking with Gigi Bowman she's a
person who's running for state Senate in
New York and she is the liberty
candidate maven she will help you figure
out how to put together your best
platform and your best campaign gee gee
thanks for talking thank you Nick
reasontv I'm Nick Gillespie
you